you were supposed to be his queen we're
not going to hold it back any longer
Queen Lea we have a message for you and
we mean business
can you just leave Audrey alone she was
obviously under a whole lot of stress
when she chose to steal the Queen's
crown and clearly you're the one to
blame for her villainous breakdown if
there's one thing that everyone noticed
it's that you're the real villain of
descendant 3 well Queen Lea was busy
trying to control her granddaughter's
life we got busy with spotting out 10
things everyone missed in d3 keep
watching to find out why Audrey was able
to touch Maleficent sceptre without
getting cursed Hades tells all we had no
idea that mal knew who her father was
but what was even more shocking was
finding out that Hades and Maleficent
were actually married once upon a time
nidia tells all during his
father-daughter duet saying that it
wasn't easy being married to mouths
mother we didn't know that weddings
happened on the Isle of the Lost
so this rapid-fire fact caught us by
surprise Audrey treats Chad like a dog
the way Audrey treats Chad proves what
most of us already knew
Audrey has zero feelings for
Cinderella's son but when it comes to
Chad it's easy to see that he would
follow Audrey to the end of the world
Audrey treats Chad like the lovesick
puppy that he is she even stroked his
hair like the top of a dog's head but
then again Chad didn't seem to mind the
Sleeping Beauty reference Queen Lea
throws some serious shade her
granddaughter's way as soon as mal and
then get engaged
she tells Audrey she isn't exactly wrong
after all
Audrey's mother is Sleeping Beauty so
this statement is totally accurate
Minnie Audrey and Ben getting dumped is
never easy which is why most of us feel
for Audrey but we felt her heartache
even more when we glanced around her
dorm at auradon prep Audrey had plenty
of pictures of her and Ben around her
room
spotted one frame which showcased Ben
and Audrey as little kids
this means that Ben was Audrey's first
love ever since she was a little girl
now that is just heartbreaking
living conditions it's hard to believe
that the people of auradon eat
scrumptious meals day in and day out
while the people of the Isle pick flies
out of their baked goods the Isles
living conditions are downright awful
just ask the V Ches
poor Gil had never even tried a great
before or picked fresh berries from a
bush the V Ches definitely deserved to
be spoiled from here on out
dude the talking dog another thing we
noticed in d3 is that dude the dog was
still able to talk this sort of confused
us since dude could only speak because
he ate a truth gummy so wouldn't he go
back to barking after a day or two that
is unless mal made Carlos an endless
supply of truth gummies so that he could
continue chatting with his best but the
Maleficent reference when Queen Leah
refused to invite Maleficent to her
daughter's christening the villain went
bonkers
and well the same can be said about
Audrey she totally embodies Maleficent
when she crashes Jane's birthday party
before putting everyone to sleep
cleanliness truth queen Liam might be
the evilest grandmother that ever lived
but that doesn't mean that she doesn't
genuinely care about Audrey Leah looks
super distressed when Audrey was
unconscious in her bed despite hating
villains Leah let Hades use his amber on
Audrey which saved her life this led to
mal wanting to open the barrier once and
for all but unlike everyone else Leah
looks super angry when mal took down the
barrier Jane's birthday cake
Jane's birthday cake looked absolutely
delicious which is why Celia and Izzy
stole a piece before Carlos could get
the cake to Jane but Celia and Izzy
weren't the only ones who ate a piece of
Jane's cake was it just us or was this
cake never-ending everyone kept cutting
out huge pieces but somehow there was
always enough cake to go around
Perry hook wants a girlfriend we love
Harry hook he's suave sleek and
everything we could ever want in a
pirate but as it turns
harry wants more from life than being
umas first me was it just us or was
harry desperately trying to find himself
a girlfriend from uma to Jane to Audrey
it's clear that Harry wants a first mate
of his own we owe you an apology
at the end of the film now Audrey and
then all managed to bury the hatchet now
invent a laundry that they owe her an
apology but funny enough they never say
I'm sorry out loud
it looks like Malin Ben need to brush up
on their auradon manners but in the end
we're just happy that audrey came back
to her senses a glowing dragon i when
Audrey breaks into the museum it's clear
that she's only after the Queen's crown
but that's when something strange
happens well if it's in scepter drag and
I start gluing a vibrant green and
calling Audrey over to it and on top of
that Audrey doesn't get cursed for 1,000
years after grabbing it
the only explanation we can think of is
that dragon I was bored and sensed
Audrey's anger and sadness making her
someone he could easily turn into a
villain did you guys notice anything
that we didn't sound off in the comments
section and that's a wrap don't forget
to like this video and subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
soon
[Music]